[Música]
la tormenta invernal Elliot comenzó a
debilitarse sin embargo miles de
personas siguen en alerta por intensas
Nevadas unos 260 mil usuarios tuvieron
que pasar la Navidad a oscuras al menos
30 personas han perdido la vida
en su determinación de luchar contra la
violencia las pandillas y el
narcotráfico el gobierno de El Salvador
cercó un barrio Popular de la capital la
medida ha causado polémica varias
organizaciones internacionales denuncian
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos
iremos hasta Ecuador en donde
conoceremos a un grupo de artesanos
locales que mantienen vivos los juegos
tradicionales como el trompo y la hoja
lata para que los jóvenes se alejen de
los dispositivos móviles y no pierdan la
habilidad de interactuar socialmente
Hola Bienvenidos a este informativo de
France 24 el que hacemos énfasis en
noticias del continente americano vamos
a comenzar en Estados Unidos en donde la
tormenta Elliot ha comenzado ya a
debilitarse sin embargo miles de
personas siguen sufriendo las
consecuencias de las intensas Nevadas y
Las bajas temperaturas algunos tuvieron
que pasar las fiestas de navidad sin
servicio de Electricidad cerca de 30
personas ya han perdido la vida Marina
sardinha nos cuenta más
la Navidad más gélida en Estados Unidos
la tormenta Elliot deja Ya al menos 30
muertos en todo el país por incidentes
relacionados con este fenómeno climático
extremo que aceptó con fuerza Buffalo en
el extremo occidental del estado de
Nueva York tras los equipos de Socorro y
la guardia nacional permanecen
desplegados para paliar los daños y la
fuerza de las Nevadas comienza a
debilitarse
prácticamente ha habido una pérdida de
vidas y las cifras siguen aumentando
hemos confirmado ya 12 muertes
relacionadas con la tormenta y por
desgracia sabemos que habrá más cifras
que se darán a conocer tan pronto como
se confirmen
este domingo muchos amanecieron después
de las fiestas navideñas todavía sin
Electricidad más de 150.000 hogares y
negocios en todo el país sufren por los
daños a la red eléctrica y miles de
vuelos Fueron cancelados por la tormenta
invernal que según explicó un
meteorólogo a France 24 es también una
consecuencia de la crisis climática
mundial
de noviembre vimos trayectorias muy
largas de ciclones que son totalmente
contrarias son se les llama de núcleo
caliente de los trópicos hasta el Polo
Norte Entonces es una reacción del
planeta para tratar de hacer el
equilibrio térmico Entonces ahora lo que
está mandando es aire frío desde el Polo
Norte hasta la actitud tropicales Y es
que el calentamiento global habría
grabado las condiciones del ciclón bomba
de Elliot puesto que el aumento de la
temperatura del planeta está evaporando
más agua la atmósfera generando más
humedad y precipitaciones convertidas en
nieve en temporada de invierno el
gobierno de El Salvador ordenó cerca de
un barrio Popular de la capital del país
como parte de su estrategia contra la
violencia las pandillas y el
narcotráfico Aunque el gobierno defiende
estas medidas diferentes organizaciones
internacionales denuncian violaciones a
los Derechos Humanos Andrés triviño nos
cuenta más
no hay tregua navideña para las
pandillas en El Salvador el gobierno del
país centroamericano ordenó acercar un
barrio Popular en la capital San
Salvador conocido por narcotráfico
terrorismo y presencia de pandillas sin
remover un solo elemento del cerco de
sollopango más de 1000 soldados y 130
agentes de la policía extraerán a los
criminales que aún quedan en esta
comunidad famosa por el narcotráfico en
marzo de 2022 El Congreso aprobó un
régimen de excepción que ha sido
ampliado nueve veces y que le permite al
gobierno realizar medidas que apoyen la
polémica propuesta de bukele con la cual
pretende acabar con el terrorismo al fin
de su mandato según cifras oficiales el
plan ha dejado a más de 58.000
integrantes de estructuras terroristas
capturados y reportes de Cero homicidios
en el país mientras que organizaciones
internacionales denuncian que el régimen
de excepción suspende derechos
constitucionales y va en contra de los
Derechos Humanos después de reportar
torturas y malos tratos pero el gobierno
defiende sus medidas
esta comunidad ha sido estigmatizada por
más de 40 años
se dedicaron a distribuir y vender droga
desde esta comunidad el régimen de
excepción está contemplado para ser
temporal sin embargo el presidente
bukele le ha dado un carácter indefinido
que parece estar lejos de su fin
y Mientras tanto en Colombia el
presidente Gustavo Petro hizo un corto
balance de sus primeros cuatro meses
como mandatario durante su alocución
Petro hizo énfasis en los diferentes
avances que ha habido en su plan
denominado Paz total para lo que pidió a
los colombianos unidad frente a este
tema El mandatario recalcó que el 2023
la paz total será un sello de Colombia
país que sostiene actualmente una mesa
de diálogo con la guerrilla del eln en
Venezuela
la Paz es otro de esos valores que dan
sentido a esta celebraciones y como
saben en nuestra meta más importante
esta noche no solo quiero desear para
Colombia una fiesta en paz quiero
también renovar con ustedes mi
compromiso para concretar por fin la tan
ansiada Paz total en nuestro país y una
joven boliviana fue reconocida por la
NASA por haber descubierto un nuevo
asteroide que ha recibido el nombre 2022
GX 13 la joven de 15 años oriunda de la
ciudad de Potosí afirmó que un profesor
la alentó a participar en una campaña
que es realizada en todo este país para
que los estudiantes busquen asteroides
tras su hallazgo enviaron el reporte a
los Estados Unidos y recibió una
certificación de la Nasa que reconoce a
la joven como la descubridora del
asteroide
porque realmente es un poco complejo
Buscar los cuerpos porque son pequeños y
hay grandes pequeños pero por lo general
suelen ser pequeños en este caso
recuerdo que era un puntito pequeñito en
la imagen de chiquito tuve que hacer
zoom tuve que buscar ver si coincidían
las imágenes si coincidían los
movimientos las características y
posteriormente los reporte y hasta hace
unos cuatro días si no me equivoco el
profesor encargado de la campaña de
de mi colegio pues me mencionó no me
dijo que había sido confirmado el
asteroide y bueno por el momento tiene
el nombre de asteroide dos gx3 en
Ecuador un grupo de artesanos intentan
preservar el juego y las relaciones
sociales a través de los juegos
tradicionales como el trompo la Hojalata
y la música estos profesionales
mantienen su oficio para que los niños
se alejen de los dispositivos
tecnológicos y el aislamiento social que
estos producen nuestro corresponsal en
Ecuador Gustavo Ortega nos cuenta la
historia
Gerardo Zavala es un artesano conocido
como El rey del trompo y se fuerza por
crear juguetes con su torno de madera
para preservar las tradiciones y
culturas sobre todo en tiempos donde los
dispositivos electrónicos son los
favoritos de los niños es el rescate de
los juegos tradicionales y que los niños
vuelvan a ser
actores y números espectadores porque
esta clase de juegos del desarrolla
destrezas que luego le servirán también
bastante en el futuro según la profesión
que escojan
Marta Pacheco también artesana de
juguetes se hace Llamar la hojalatera de
la ronda desde los 7 años comenzó con su
padre el oficio yo elaboro el
tradicional [__] nacional con el que los
niños juegan a ser autoridad de tránsito
también ollas cocinas y tambores se
cuentan entre sus creaciones para ella
la infancia Se está perdiendo porque los
niños ya no quieren los juegos
tradicionales y nos sentamos y
compartimos el té compartamos nuevamente
hagamos el arroz hagamos la sopita y
vamos a compartir con nuestros hijos y
vamos a comer y con nuestros niños
enseñarles nuevamente el valor del
tambor canciones muy fáciles A
diferencia de la artesanía Samuel
cartaya canta para fomentar vínculos
entre padres e hijos es un músico
terapeuta sus composiciones van
dirigidas a romper el aislamiento que
provocan los dispositivos electrónicos
nos hemos desviado un poco hacia el lado
de los objetos de regalar el juguete y
no construir el juego es muy importante
entender que lo que realmente hace que
Nuestros peques crezcan sanos y y se
desarrollen de manera ideal no es que
estén rodeados de juguetes sino que
estén rodeados de juego juegos unos que
tres artesanos pero se mantengan el
tiempo las relaciones sociales actitudes
y el carácter de los niños frente a la
sociedad
y con esto llegamos al final de las
noticias más información en France
24.com siga con nuestra programación
[Música]